heck did I end up over here cuz this was
not part of the plan at all and it just
started from your Redemption wasn't part
of the plan because again I was all
ready just call me uh what are you doing
I'm playing middle name uh we're gonna
fried I got em I got a camera for
today we shouldn't Friday well we're
gonna feisty I'm like look what is
the script just gonna shoot it Jess it
was awesome that was the classic version
of winging it Naga that was literally
like the whole shoot was uh it was just
literally we had access to a red camera
we had it for the weekend and it was
just like we're gonna do something with
it over the cat I you know I want to do
action films you know I saw it I knew it
obviously with angel you know he was
going to be my start it's late let's do
an action film we had nobody you know
time to rehearse angels looking at dudes
not committed nobody's committed well
I'm committed let's go so you know
that's how I ended up being in it was
purely out of necessity was ok I'll do
it with you because you know again same
thing with Hollywood is tough to get
people to stick with it and stay with
you especially when it's all for no
money so you know it's uh so when I knew
we had to committed actors it was me and
him so we went and did it and uh oh
you're a pirate and he was a camera
operator and DP and lighting guy was
literally just like four of us it was it
was me angel Pedro and my son CJ and he
was handling like they're the peeing and
helping with the lights and wiping sweat
off and all out of crab and and we just
went for it you know no Lighting's in a
no rehearsal and then literally just sat
around with no fights Alito oh you
thought for the first take before we
start fighting is like well what are we
gonna like locking it
what the heck are we gonna do I'm gonna
come running at you and try to take your
head off get out the way yeah absolutely
I don't know the first shot of the fight
sequences like okay I'm gonna run it
trying to take your head off get out of
the way that's how it started if we just
kind of winded the whole way but uh we
had a lot of trust in each other and
that's how we were able to get through
that because I've worked with other
martial artists other fighters in doing
the sequence and it was different it was
different it's like when you have that
trust it was just you know it was just a
lot it was effortless working with angel
it was tiring but it was the alien was
effortless and he kicks hard you can't
be kicking me in this one spot of my leg
and knowledge as I all right doesn't
know I have my footprint on my chest
from here kicking me in the chest the
grooves from his sneakers in my chest I
gotta complain it goes little here take
take ten I'm like well you sure you guys
yes let's go let's go let's go I'm like
thank 16 I'm like you sure Malcolm kick
you again that was that was compared
reaction angel didn't you set up where
you guys were really hitting each other
yeah we actually out cuz again to make
the fight look real you know we had a
really punch each other except the face
from the leg to the body everything here
would go straight hard yeah except for
the faces of Everything Everything
Everything says bring me when he jumps
on my shoulders and he's elbowing me on
my head i slayed up to the ground and
stuff free that was when I was it was
ahead I got I got his head and it was
Laurel concrete just grabbed me bombs
manolito they hurt nobody he looked good
on TV and that's actually one of the
staples I want to do with all my action
films because I think um as a fighter
I've always looked at you know
traditionally American action films
because Hong Kong action films the
martial artists are such highly trained
athletes that they could pretty much do
anything and not know each other and
jump into a scene that quick because
they have so much control over their
bodies and what they're doing and
artist but in the states you have a lot
especially in action films you have a
lot of actors who are hired for their
acting and then the fighting is
secondary they get in their train for
three months to do a particular scene
but they're only trained to do that
scene so it's kind of like and as a
fighter i can always recognize that
because is there there's a there's a way
you have your balance there's a way
where you project your force and when
you're doing things like that and and
you know it's in the camera work they
tend to hide little things like the
footwork and that tells you if a person
is really doing something and not
because I can fake a punch and stand
here or i can go wide screen and show
you how the punch is really executed and
you can see the real force of it so it's
just I want to try a different technique
on a shooting films that will allow you
to see the full action without too many
quick cuts so you can see how the fight
would actually develop instead of a lot
of quick cuts that is just fast fast
fast fast that is over this is the web
design the area you know and it's just
like I want you to actually see how the
fight transpires so Redemption was my
first attempt at that and you know we'll
make more we'll make more so amber is
not going to be Amber's more of a
character driven and a you know
story-driven film so is its action but
it's not going to be that type of action
you never see angel jumping off the wall
doing spinning kicks we're gonna do that
in the next man but uh and this one it's
more uh he's he's an average guy in that
that's that's the one thing I really
like about amber is one of the the tag
lines as anyone can be a hero so in the
story he's a regular guy hanging out on
the street that just happens to you know
get thrust in this and he has his
chances to step out of those situation
and say I'm not going to save the kids
but he chooses to stay in it and stay
engaged and uh you know it's those
choices if every character has chances
in the story where it's kind of like a
baton where the situation gets past two
different people where they have choices
where they could either stop or keep
going and what happens in the film would
determine whether these people keep
going and what happens to the child and
it's about all these ordinary people who
make extraordinary choices and
in the end result is you know the
benefit of the children involved
you